I think everybody does this I was
driving into work today and I had the
radio on
and Neil Diamond's song came on forever
in blue jeans oh you know that one
moaning it talks but it don't sing and
dance and it don't walk
me forever in blue jeans and I remember
you know when you hear a song it takes
you right back to that moment in time I
remembered it was time to go to school
and my clock radio went on this would be
in the 1970s whenever that song was a
hit and I'm up in the attic of my
parents house because that's where they
made me live which is really like
Flowers in the Attic you just forgotten
child they would throw
a roast up there every now and then
but I was living at the end of the hall
in the attic and uh it was really cold
up there I remember that
um like put your feet on the floor and
it was really cold and I don't know why
because Heat's supposed to rise but uh
for some reason in our house it didn't
um and anyway I can still picture the
clock radio it was a gift from my uh
Uncle Gavin who is my godfather and the
clock radio uh came on and Neil Diamond
song came on and I was listening to it
it was a big hit at the time
and I thought that the song was called
reverend blue jeans and so for years I
was like it's Reverend blue jeans
and I and and then it wasn't till years
later that someone said to me oh I love
that song Forever in Blue Jeans and I
just got really quiet because I knew
that I've been living a lie and then I
realized there were so many times and I
I think this is maybe peculiar I mean I
know a lot of people do this but the
song Dirty deeds and they're done dirt
cheap yeah I swear to God I used to sing
it as Dirty deeds and they're Dunder G
which doesn't even nothing I just
thought oh they're Australian oh I just
thought oh these Aussies they're
probably like it's Dirty Deeds you know
oh it's a Dunta Jane you know and so
G and it does sound like like a
didgeridoo and like a wallaby mixed up
wallaby didgeridoo yeah you know shrimp
on the Bobby dungeon dungeon and so I
remember singing it really loudly in the
back of our uh our family station wagon
and going and that Dirty deeds and
they're done dirty and my brother Luke
was like what the is your problem
it's done dirt cheap and again I was
humiliated but I just so I started
thinking about these today on the way
over which is just how
um how I would
and I remember I swear to God that
famous song
um uh Van Morrison's famous song uh
Brown Eyed Girl yeah there's that part
where he says
um and I swear to God I wasn't even
trying to be funny but when I first
heard that song and I didn't know what
the dirty implication was but I used to
sing because he says that part where
um hey there we go days when the rain
changes you know and then he gets the
part where he says
um going down the old mine with a
transistor radio like go down into the
old mime with the transistor radio is
what we used to do and listen to music
I thought it was
and I'm not people are going to say oh
you're making this up I'm not making it
up I honestly thought it was going down
on an old man for a transition
oh my God I think when I was a kid
and when I was a kid I love that song
and I'd be like going down on an old man
for a transistor radio
and I didn't know what going down meant
I just you know it's first of all you
can't understand Van Morrison oh
that just caught just the whole scenario
so then later on when I start to figure
out what that means I'm like
that better be a really good transistor
radio he's just sitting on a park bench
going hey blue boy you like music
oh sure and I do I like music
do you like Subterranean environment
work music there lad
but I honestly did used to sing and now
just in defiance because that song comes
on all the time when that song comes on
when it gets to that part
going down on an old man for a
transistor radio
do you remember that song we think
you're tough and I mean we're talking
about Belfast that's where he grew up
yeah I'm sure it was hard to procure a
good transistor radio you did what you
could and if old man McGinty had one uh
you do what you got to do and what if
the kid like got it because he wanted to
give it to his parents for a Christmas
gift or something you know yeah yeah
there's a sweet story but then it's like
that there's that oh Henry twist which
is the gift they got him is that you
never have to give a to an old
man a certificate that says you never
have to do that
and uh that's how he got them the
transistor radio
do you remember that old song that goes
uh I might like you better if we slept
together yeah yeah I thought it was my
mother'd get better if we slept together
hey that's a line I used to use a lot in
the 80s my mother's ill but she might
improve if we were to have sexual
relations never worked
um that's uh yeah I think there's a lot
of those yeah I think a lot of us do it
we mishear things and uh I I no I I
don't I think I think I get 90 of the
lyrics I sing is this because we learned
in a previous segment that you have
perfect hearing and that no no no no I'm
saying I don't hear the lyrics properly
I think I think I am the uh opposite of
what a musician of who a musician wants
to listen to their music because I don't
really listen to the lyrics
when I was at Saturday Night Live Mike
Myers told me that he thought ELO's hit
song uh the evil woman yeah was medieval
I thought that too but I think that's a
very common there's a few of those like
no one else thought it was Dirty deeds
and they're done no and no one in the
history of the world thought this kid is
blowing an old man to get a transistor
radio that's pretty good yeah yeah I
have to say when I get it wrong I really
get it wrong yeah that's I mean it's
almost an art what you're doing yeah
well I am the Joyce of my time
um just some woman named Joyce just a
woman named Joyce she's her carpool
night is Thursday his Thursdays
not choice no oh for God's sake not that
choice
uh uh right apologies to everyone who
will never hear Brown Eyed Girl the same
way again